Hi, welcome to the coding portion of lesson five.
Your Conference Central application is now in full swing,
you can save conference and profile entities all day
and all night long if you want to. However, every
hit to the data store counts against your application's
daily quota. The good thing is that you can
use Memcache to save your entity data to reduce
the hits to the data store. In this lesson you're
going to find out just how easy it is
to save your entities data in memcache using objectify.
In fact, it's so easy that you're going to do
another exercise to use underlying Java data store API
to put values into Memcache and to get them
back out. We're going to create announcements about conferences
that are nearly sold out, and store those announcements
in Memcache. There's no need to save the announcements
in the datastore, because they're so transient in nature.
Another thing your going to do is use task cues.
So that your application can so work in the
background. You're going to use task queues to send conformation
email anytime anybody creates a new conference. To wrap
it all up, we'll set up a cron job to
periodically check for conference that have nearly sold out
and update the announcement in Memcache. Let's get to it.